[Music]
take a minute to enjoy this view the og
co-host reuniting for the show's 25th
anniversary thank you for being a friend
debbie matanopoulos documented the girls
night out dinner with star jones joy
behar and meredith vieira in new york
city and according to star's grid post
the ladies were back together for a tv
special honoring the show's silver
anniversary she captioned the pic
wouldn't you like to have been a fly on
the wall at our post tape dinner and
called the women her sisters question of
the day is if you were laid up in a
hospital bed who would you want in the
bed next to you i picked gavin rossdale
from bush we don't know who he is that's
the crew in their first season together
back in 1997.
joy was actually just a guest member of
the panel back then she went full time
halfway through season one and still
co-hosts the show to this day
well it's a long run i mean you know i
always say that longevity is is the most
important thing in this industry because
most people don't last that long and i'm
very
grateful that i could
now this isn't the first time the
original crews come back together
please welcome back i love them all
meredith vieira
all four plus every other co-host up to
that point came home to the view stage
back in 2014 for creator barbara walters
send-off show i actually enjoy coming
back for guests
and to celebrate the views success so
good for them and in honor of the
talker's milestone year star debbie and
meredith have all been invited back to
guest co-hosts in season 25 as part of a
series of celebratory surprises i think
they're surprising us too i know we
don't know that much about what's
happening
season 25 wraps up this summer so stay
tuned for that reunion special and in
the meantime
take a little time to enjoy the view
[Music]